l'économie française est peu exposée à
la Russie c'est ce qu'a déclaré ce matin
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances Bruno Le Maire le gouvernement
minimise relativise en tout cas les
effets de sanction surtout pour la
France mais les bourses elles ont bien
chuté ce matin on retrouve Thomas
Pellerin Carlin directeur du Centre
énergie de l'Institut Jacques Delors et
chercheur à cet institut bonjour quels
peuvent être les conséquences
énergétiques notamment sur le gaz
alors à ce stade les sanctions
européennes ne vissent pas
particulièrement ni le gaz ni le pétrole
par contre ce qu'on anticipe est-ce
qu'on voit déjà c'est une hausse des
prix sur les marchés internationaux
parce que les investisseurs évidemment
ont une grande inquiétude et du coup
cette inquiétude génère une hausse des
prix sur les marchés actuellement est-ce
qu'il y aura des effets sur les
carburants est-ce que les prix de
l'énergie vont continuer à flamber à la
pompe
alors les prix l'énergie vont continuer
à être élevés mais on n'est pas encore
dans un scénario historique là
actuellement le prix du baril de pétrole
est autour de 100 dollars c'était le
prix moyen pendant toute l'année 2012
2013 et le début de l'année 2014 donc là
on a pas vraiment de flan paix
exceptionnelle des prix par contre on a
la continuation d'une tendance haussière
avec des prix TGV et donc quelles vont
être les conséquences pour les Européens
et les Russes actuellement de ces
sanctions prises
sur l'énergie en fait pour l'instant il
y a très peu de conséquences l'Europe
n'a pas du tout adopté ni d'embargo sur
le gaz ni dans Barrow sur le pétrole
alors que ça avait été fait il y a 10
ans pour amener l'Iran à négocier sur
son programme nucléaire donc à ce stade
on voit que voilà si je peux dire comme
ça notre notre boulimie pour les
énergies fossiles en Europe continue à
fournir des revenus à la Russie la
Russie reçoit environ 100 milliards de
dollars par an de l'Europe pour les
achats de pétrole et de gaz et une
grande partie cet argent est investi
dans l'armée russe qui est aujourd'hui à
l'oeuvre en Ukraine
quelle sera l'impact
[Musique]
alors pour nous Européens les
alternatives c'est de voir si on fait le
choix de se passer très rapidement du
pétrole et du gaz russe si on refait
l'effort qu'on avait fait après le choc
pétrolier 1973 on avait un autre
problème cette fois-ci avec le pétrole
saoudien et on a investi énormément dans
l'efficacité énergétique et dans le
développement de source d'énergie
alternatives à l'époque le nucléaire et
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui la capacité
d'avoir cette même volonté politique et
de faire en 2022 ce qui est bon à faire
en 2022 sobriété énergétique rénovation
des bâtiments déploiement des énergies
renouvelables de manière à réduire le
plus vite possible nos dépendance au gaz
au pétrole russe donc il y a des leçons
à attirer de ce qui se passe en ce
moment à moyen terme en tout cas
très clairement elle a le son à tirer ça
aurait été mieux de la tirer cette leçon
là en 2014 ou en 2008 mais cette leçon
est que pour l'instant factuellement
notre boulimie d'énergie fossile finance
l'armée russe
est-ce que la question enfin parce que
ça c'est dans le débat actuellement pour
la campagne présidentielle en France
est-ce que la question de l'énergie
nucléaire peut-être une solution est-ce
qu'elle aura pas à terme à une place
importante pour assurer notre
indépendance énergétique
alors la question du nucléaire n'a
aucune importance dans la situation
actuelle simplement parce qu'il faut 10
à 15 ans pour construire un réacteur
nucléaire donc là si on veut avoir un
impact il faut agir très rapidement dans
les mois et quelques années à venir donc
vraiment voilà installer pompe à chaleur
ça prend 2 jours construire un nouveau
rectangle nucléaire ça prend 15 ans donc
on peut tout à fait investir dans le
nucléaire si on le souhaite mais c'est
quelque chose qui changera la donne à
l'horizon 2035 2040 pas dans l'horizon
de temps qui est qui est celui de
l'urgence géopolitique actuelle
la solution selon vous
ensuite l'efficacité énergétique rénover
les bâtiments les bureaux les écoles les
bases militaires les logements etc etc
et ensuite le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables en particulier celle qui
peuvent s'installer très rapidement les
pompes à chaleur les chauffe-eau solaire
les panneaux photovoltaïques tous ces
sources d'énergie qui nous permettraient
de très rapidement réduire notre
consommation de gaz et pour le pétrole
c'est évidemment voilà utilise-moi la
voiture déployer les transports en
commun et accélérer le passage vers le
véhicule électrique là vraiment ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que ce qui est
essentiel pour notre avenir climatique
et ce qui est essentiel pour notre
indépendance géopolitique cette année
c'est la même chose donc on a deux très
très bonnes raisons de faire ça
dernière question on parle de faire
venir du gaz de schiste américain pour
l'Allemagne ou du gaz du Qatar ces
alternatives ou paraissent-elles
crédible et ensuite sur le plan
écologique qu'elles peuvent en être les
conséquences
de gaz naturel liquéfier qu'on apporte
du monde entier les États-Unis et le
Qatar certes mais aussi le Nigéria
l'Australie etc le gaz de le gaz naturel
et caissier à un impact énergétique et
climatique un petit peu plus grave que
le gaz russe transporté par par gazoduc
mais on est vraiment sur sur l'épaisseur
du trait le cœur de l'action dans tous
les cas ça va être vraiment la réduction
de la demande et en gaz en pétrole par
l'efficacité énergétique et par les
énergies renouvelables c'est ça vraiment
que nous européen on doit faire de
manière urgente on aurait dû le faire
dès 2014 on aurait dû faire dès le 2008
mais mieux retard que jamais merci
beaucoup Thomas pelleras Carla en
t'avoir été avec nous sur France 24 et
merci pour